- I would totally marry Kate McKinnon.
Seriously.
(upbeat music)
- I love a good flannel.
I guess that makes me a stereotype.
- I've seen Tegan and Sara
in concern like five times.
- I wish I could grow my nails out.
- Oh, yeah, I only watch Grey's Anatomy
for Callie and Arizona.
- I don't think the ending
of Bend it Like Beckham was realistic.
- You know, I feel like I
should be good at softball.
- Oh, my favorite movie's Carol.
I really identify with Cate Blanchett.
- Women are just better kissers, you know?
- I don't know.
I think Rory and Paris
were low-key dating.
- Did you hear the finally came out
and said Wonder Woman is bi?
It's like all right,
some good representation in comic books.
- Oh, I would totally
go to a women's festival
every weekend if I could, you know?
Ladies only.
- I really love tacos.
Like the food and vagi--
- Oh, my ex liked the movie.
My ex-girlfriend, I should say.
- I just wish that
someone would look at me
the way Holland Taylor
looks at Sarah Paulson.
- Aren't boobs the best?
Man, I love boobs.
- Oh, by the way, I love vagina.
(laughs) Wow.
Oh, sorry, I was just
thinking about how gay I am.
Gay as fuck.